Québec la Cour supérieure du Québec
refuse de réviser l'accord conclu en
1969 sur le prix de l'électricité
produite à Churchill forz au Labrador et
Ricky Landry selon Terre-Neuve et
Labrador cette entente est injuste oui
exactement parce qu'en 2010 au moment où
la société d'énergie Terre-Neuve a
déposer cette requête devant la Cour
supérieure du Québec le Québec avant
poché 22 milliards de dollars de profits
grâce à Church offert neuve avait
empoché un seul milliard de dollars de
profits donc c'est une entente qui
profite largement au Québec pourquoi
mais c'est qu'au moment de la signature
du contraire en 1969 ça avait été prévu
que Terre-Neuve vendait son électricité
au Québec qui parle la suite le vendeur
ses clients et le prix de l'énergie
avait été fixé pour la durée du contrat
qui est de 65 ans donc pas d'inflation
prévue le Québec paye toujours pour
chaque kilowattheure d'énergie un quart
d'un cent c'est très peu selon
Terre-Neuve c'est un juste et donc
Internet va déposer cette requête en
cours supérieur pour tenter de forcer la
renégociation du contraste que refuse
Québec donc aujourd'hui le juge de la
course période du Québec a dit que
d'ignorer les provisions du contraste
d'ignorer tous les coups et les risques
le Québec avait assumer au moment de la
signature du contrat donc il y a le PDG
de la société d'énergie terre de Vienne
qui dit aujourd'hui qu'il intergeta
appel et que ça pourrait même se rendre
jusqu'au cours suprême du Canada s'il le
faut
jusqu'en 2041 merci Ricky au revoir